con 221 votos a favor y 202 en contra la
cámara de representantes aprobó la
resolución continua para financiar el
gobierno hasta el 18 de febrero del
próximo año ahora la votación pasará al
senado donde hay resistencia de algunos
senadores republicanos la fecha límite
para aprobar este aumento en el
presupuesto de funcionamiento es hasta
este viernes 3 de diciembre pero varios
senadores republicanos como ter cruise
de texas mike y de yuta y roger marchan
de kansas entre otros están afirmando
que no apoyarán la resolución continua
si la administración de bailén no
suspende su mandato de vacunas es decir
que ellos sólo apoyarían la financiación
del gobierno si va de echa para atrás el
mandato de que todas las empresas con
más de 100 empleados tengan que vacunar
obligatoriamente a sus trabajadores
antes del 4 de enero del 2022 mandato en
este momento está efectivamente
bloqueado por parte de una corte de
apelaciones y la misma administración ha
dicho que no lo ejercerá los 100
senadores en todo demócratas y
republicanos tienen que pasar esta ley
de forma unánime por reglamentos del
congreso y si esto no ocurre a partir de
este viernes en la medianoche el
gobierno de eeuu dejará de tener fondos
para operar y varios programas contra el
cob y parques nacionales y agencias
federales entre otros
dejarían de operar